[Music]
here in this video we will again go back
to the monsterverse and assess the
powers and capabilities of titanium's
rodan as well as take a look at the
titans that rodan can defeat as well as
the ones he cannot
well mostly we will focus on the ones
that he can beat
and give reasons as to how it's possible
for him to put them down he is one of
the tyrants that are powerful enough to
even challenge alpha tyrants like
ghidorah and mothra although he was
defeated by them both he will also not
be able to take on godzilla and tiamat
since the latter can drag him down to
the oceans by its hydro-kinetic powers
so with that out of the way let's now
get down to business
history the monster verse is a
multiverse of monsters rodan is a
prehistoric reptilian airborne super
species that co-evolved with other huge
monsters like godzilla and the other
tyrants and interacted with mankind
during prehistoric times rhoda and
species has a lot in common with
pterosaurs although they don't appear to
be related well after his parents nested
on a volcano in ireland amara in mexico
one of the species members was born
there his birthplace became his home and
resting place next we'll talk a little
bit on the design of rodan this
incarnation of rodan has a larger
wingspan compared to any of his previous
incarnations over 871 feet from tip to
tip his physique overall bears a strong
resemblance to a bird of prey his head
possesses a large heavy beak lined with
tooth like spikes and a pair of horns
that curl down from the back of his
skull
rodan's skin is burgundy colored and
possesses a texture similar to molten
rock with bumps and ridges along his
chest and back he is 154 feet tall and
weighs 39 000 tons as well as being
biovolcanic in nature with molten magma
running through his epidermal skin layer
so what are his powers
rodin possesses an internal volcanic
combustion system causing him to radiate
heat the temperature of which can reach
up to 1200 degrees celsius as a result
rodin's external body temperature is
life-threateningly hot upon close
contact he was able to slowly burn
mothra to near death rodin's massive
wings are powerful enough to create
devastating sonic thunderclaps his body
is heavily armored and can withstand
massive amounts of damage his sharp
talents and beak are his main weapons as
well as his extremely hot temperature
plus his wings he can also make
volcanoes explode when flying over them
as described in the novelization
so the first titan that he can clearly
defeat is titanus amhulic although we
can say for a fact that rodan will not
be able to defeat behemoth since
behemoth has fireproof skin but he does
have a clear advantage over amherst the
one who defeated behemoth so it might be
a little bit confusing right if amhulu
can defeat behemoth and rodan cannot
beat behemoth then surely amhulu can
kill rodan right wrong amhulu is
essentially a nervous system with a
massive brain that can tell it
kinetically assemble a body mostly made
of trees and roots of plants and that's
where the disadvantage lies with a
temperature of over 1200 degrees rodan
can just slowly burn amherst into
submission by being near him
so the second tyrant is warbat wabats
are large reptilian serpentine creatures
equipped with two red membranous wings
running down the top half of its body
supported by long spines which are
extensions of their rib cage they can
fly and their main mode of attack is
constriction so you see where i'm going
with this a robot facing off with rodan
will only end with the snake titan being
burned to a crisp the wing membranes
will be vaporized and a constriction
move will only end in its death
so after the warbat the muto male will
be the next island on this list that
will clearly fall against rodan on a
one-on-one fight well versus the two
mutos at once rodin will most likely die
but facing them one on one he will
surely win against them for one the muto
male is physically weaker than rodan and
cannot counter his speed even in the air
and for the case of the female she has
one massive vulnerability she is
hexapetal walks on all six and looks
down while her back faces upwards which
is where rodan is he can just swoop down
and pick her off piece by piece
attacking her back
but then again rodan will not be able to
take on the muto prime as this beast is
something different it has a sonic roll
that can disorient him and extra hard
armor as well as being more flexible in
combat with massive arms that can crush
rodan quickly if it gets its hands on
him
well the next one on this list of losers
is the skull crawler we are not talking
about ramarok the big one from skull
island 2017 it is clearly smaller and
will die in a quick fight but we are
talking about the one from godzilla vs
kong the red skull crawler it is vicious
and hyper carnivorous being ferocious
and very hostile to any living creature
small or titanic but again like the of
female it is clearly disadvantaged
because it is largely terrestrial and
subterranean and so it has never
developed defense mechanisms against
airborne titans and also it isn't armed
enough to withstand rodin's attacks from
the air and his extreme heat
now we come to two flying titans that
can give rodan a run for his money one
is camazotz and the other is shinomura
camazotz is a tough one and the fight
could go either way firstly camazotz has
a supersonic screech that can disorient
the fire demon and can also match his
flight as well as summon storms to
quench his fire but when it comes to the
killing blow kamzas doesn't have one it
does have brute strength as shown in the
fight with kong but it cannot kill rodan
with biting or talents and will
eventually succumb to the relentless
heat
next is shinomura a tyrant that was
hunted constantly by godzilla shinomura
is a swarm to item that lasted a long
while against the king of the monsters
just because it can fly away and fight
another day
shinomura is made up of a ton of smaller
organisms that work in unison and their
main weakness is fire or heat the two
shinamuras were killed by godzilla's
atomic breath and a nuclear bomb so when
it comes to blows between rodan and
shinomura the former would likely win
but it would take quite a while to get
all the smaller collective organisms
burned to a crisp shinamura on the other
hand would be near useless to inflict
damage on rodan except for blunt blows
so there you have it the titans that can
lose against rodan
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video and with that we come to the end
of it so hit that like button for
support subscribe and most of all smash
that bell icon for regular updates on
new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam